FABULOUS.
"SPECIAL REPORT" IS NEXT.
GUESS WHO'S BACK?
BRET BAIER.
>> Bret: CONGRATULATIONS.
♪ ♪
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
I'M BRET BAIER IN WASHINGTON.
WE ARE IN OUR WAY FROM WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLS A
MAJOR STATEMENT BY SOUTH KOREA
ABOUT NORTH KOREA.
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF DELIVERING
THIS NEWS ABOUT THE NEWS TO
REPORTERS IN THE BRIEFING ROOM A
SHORT TIME AGO.
>> SOUTH KOREA'S GONNA BE MAKING
A MAJOR STATEMENT.
SPEAK UP ON WATT, MR. PRESIDENT?
'S TICKET BIG SUBJECT.
>> Bret: AND THAT WAS IT, KIND
OF CRYPTIC.
JOHN ROBERTS STARTS US OFF WITH
BREAKING NEWS FROM THE NORTH
LAWN.
GOOD EVENING, JOHN.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET BY THE
PRESIDENT WENT ON TO SAY A
LITTLE FURTHER ON IN THAT
EXCHANGE, THE ANNOUNCEMENT
TONIGHT WOULD BE ABOUT
NORTH KOREA.
WE DO NOT KNOW WHAT THE
SUBSTANCE OF THAT WILL BE.
WE DO KNOW IT WAS THE PRESIDENT
SPEAKING WITH THE SOUTH KOREAN
PRESIDENT ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
THE NORTH KOREAN -- THE
SOUTH KOREAN RATHER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR IS EXPECTED TO
BE IN THAT BRIEFING ROOM TO
DELIVER US THE NEWS.
HE HAS BEEN HERE ALL DAY, ALONG
WITH HIS STAFF TALKING WITH
H.R. MCMASTER ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED EARLIER IN THE WEEK
BETWEEN NORTH KOREA AND
SOUTH KOREA, WHERE THE NORTH
SAID IT WOULD BE HELPING TO MEET
WITH MOON JAE-IN AND THIS WOULD
BE KIM JONG UN WHO WOULD
ACTUALLY COME INTO SOUTH KOREA
TERRITORY TO MEET AT THE PEACE
HOUSE AT THE BORDER CROSSING,
WHICH I KNOW, BRET, YOU ARE VERY
FAMILIAR WITH.
SOMETIME IN LATE MAY.
THAT COULD BE THE STARTING POINT
FOR DIRECT TALKS BETWEEN THE
UNITED STATES AND NORTH KOREA.
IT WAS INTERESTING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT COMING IN, THE FIRST
TIME SINCE HE'S BEEN PRESIDENT,
430 DAYS THAT HE'S STUCK HIS
NOSE INTO HIS TOES INTO THE
BRIEFING ROOM.
HE DIDN'T GET ALL THE WAY IN BUT
A SURPRISE TO SEE HIM THERE.
THIS ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT
NORTH KOREA FROM SOUTH KOREA
COMES ON A DAY WHEN THE
PRESIDENT MADE HIS LONG-AWAITED
ANNOUNCEMENT ON TRADE TARIFFS,
SOMETHING THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN PROMISING SINCE THE
ELECTION CAMPAIGN.
TODAY, HE DID IT.
THE SANCTIONS ON ALUMINUM AND
STEEL ARE THE FIRST IMPOSED BY
THE U.S. IN 16 YEARS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP INSISTING THEY
ARE NECESSARY TO PROTECT
AMERICA'S NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> A STRONG STEEL AND ALUMINUM
INDUSTRY ARE VITAL TO OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
ABSOLUTELY VITAL.
STEEL IS STEEL.
YOU DON'T HAVE STEEL, YOU DON'T
HAVE A COUNTRY.
>> EVEN AS HE MOVED TO PUNISH
NATIONS HE SAYS ARE UNFAIRLY
DUMPING CHEAP STEEL INTO THE
U.S., THE PRESIDENT WAS TALKING
ABOUT CARVING OUT EXCLUSIONS FOR
CERTAIN COUNTRIES.
EXEMPTING CANADA AND MEXICO, AT
LEAST FOR NOW.
>> WE NEED STEEL, WE NEED
ALUMINUM.
WE NEGOTIATING WITH MEXICO, WE
ARE NEGOTIATING WITH CANADA.
AND THE NAFTA.
DEPENDING ON WHETHER OR NOT WE
REACH A DEAL, ALSO VERY MUCH
INVOLVED WITH THAT AS NATIONAL
DEFENSE, BUT IF WE REACH A DEAL,
IT IS MOST LIKELY THAT WE WANT
TO BE CHARGING THOSE TWO
COUNTRIES THE TARIFFS.
>> THERE MAY BE OTHER
CARVE OUTS, TOO.
FOR EXAMPLE THE STEEL MILL IN
SHEFFIELD ENGLAND PRODUCES
CASTINGS THAT ARE USED IN THE
WEAPON SYSTEM OF THE NEW
COLUMBIA CLASS NUCLEAR
SUBMARINES.
IF PRESIDENT TRUMP SLAPS TARIFFS
ON BRITAIN, THEY WOULD BE
TEXTING ITS OWN SUPPLY CHAIN'S.
>> WE HAVE OTHER COUNTRIES WITH
THAT ARE VERY MUCH INVOLVED IN
TRADE BUT ALSO MILITARY AND
WORKING WITH MILITARY.
WE'LL BE MAKING A DECISION AS TO
WHO THEY ARE.
>> BUT SOME OF AMERICA'S
EUROPEAN ALLIES ALIGNED UNDER
THE EUROPEAN UNION TRADE
COLLECTIVE ARE PLANNING
RETALIATION.
>> >> Translator: THE EUROPEAN
COMMISSION WILL INTRODUCE
COUNTERMEASURES TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S VERY